that's what i said i said it right there
i was like it's like i was like you a
woman
i'm a man there's a difference between
oh what
they bumping up in here here it is it's
going off yo
which one are y'all mother
[ __ ] me i did
you gonna do it
oh
my friends holding me you lucky cause
i'll take your head off
don't hold me back dog don't hold me
back oh okay and don't worry
see i know though if i were to lunge at
you right now
my friend right here he catch me at the
last possible second no no no i won't
but my friend does have the cognizance
to tell me i don't need to be going up
and
committing capital murder up in a club
tonight hold on just knock him
unconscious dog
pam i'm gonna kill anybody
no need for that success
tear them up i will
but wait anyway let me finish my
sentence sir
i will
oh snap you know what you lucky my boy's
using his telekinetic powers to hold me
back right now
no i'm not well maybe
it's the type of telekinesis that's a
mutant power
that you didn't realize you had until
the moment it starts
oh i got it i see i see it so you want
me to hold you
i'm a dragon oh oh yeah i want to rip
this i'm a lion
i'm a tiger over here i'm a bear oh my
oh i go crazy on you oh i can't believe
him and man he's like he's like a
tornado i mean
don't hold me back i can't even believe
i can hold him back i can't even do it
man believe i'm this strong let me go
look at this house i'm one arm in it i
can't even believe i'm this strong let
me
look at this matter like a little baby
he can't get past me he's like a little
owl what
what you i'm a little baby i'm holding
you back man
stupid yeah i got carried away i
apologize what you mean you got carried
away you told me i hold you back i was
holding your back what do you want me to
do in a fight situation new means no
and yes means yes how would i have known
that so oh
what come on man ow come on that hurt
and you holding me back now thank you
very much for that
okay we'll just at least change it up
okay now you listen